[Music]
so we got a good story to share today
okay just one
a dad bravely jumps on an unconscious
son to save him from a raging bull oh i
saw him wearing a rodeo
on i need to show you why was his son
even oh he like
did a human shield no he was he was he
was the what do they call him rodeo
clown clown yeah so he's on the the bull
no the clowns are the ones that distract
the bulls you'll see right now
this is the the sun is on the boat
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the bowl doing that crazy isn't that
creepy that his dad jumps on his kid
like that
i thought you said like he jumped on his
son like he was stomping on his son but
that's not
i think this is a feel-good article like
m bison stomping the goodness of it i
guess the dad felt pretty good he
finished dude
[Laughter]
that's a real creep i don't know
[Laughter]
why did his dad have to body roll though
while he's on him yeah he was gyrating
his hips a little bit why was that bull
interrupting he didn't even see the bull
he just jumped out of his son
whoa what the [ __ ] his son was finally
knocked down he was like perfect time
when the ball was hitting him he's like
wait you're tired
god dude
he's so horny oh oh yeah i feel like huh
it's it's weird because i guarantee you
there's some homophobic [ __ ] in
the audience going
[ __ ] millennials when he sees that
[ __ ] that ain't right i don't know about
that at the rodeo oh he's dead right
yeah all right fine that's a rodeo come
on dude rodeo never no no i want to go
i'm during homophobe tonight
[Laughter]
it was honestly one of the coolest
things i've ever done really yeah
because you well i was also young and so
like that was my first time traveling
overseas to europe in general so just
being out there there's already that
euphoria and then participating in like
a worldwide cultural event where like
everybody flies into this little city
called pamplona for this like saint
francis day and then when you're running
from the bulls right like as you get
ready in the morning they give you these
little pamphlets to talk about how like
hey like if you fall or whatever do this
or do this and remember you might die
and you're just kind of like oh [ __ ]
everybody's down to maybe die today but
honestly more scary than the bulls are
the people you try to like jump over the
fence or something the people just push
you back in or like dads will jump on
you and mountain you yeah yeah if you
fall
[Laughter]
dance if you call your fair game
don't even [ __ ] think about it
there's just a bunch of dads on the side
just waiting read the bad place like be
careful
all right come back
dad's licking the lips
we got a lot of problem solving
they like trip kids like oops
the bull's an excuse
it's one of the longest running
pedophilia [ __ ]
vehicles yeah oh my
god how do we uncover this right now we
can ruin the cover that's who keeps the
bull running going like to the goodness
back to the goodness this dad in the u.s
okay this dad in the u.s is being dubbed
father of the year arrested
that's what i think
me and steve were in solidarity can't
believe that turned into this i know i
want to see i really i genuinely looked
at this i was like oh snap this is like
a really really cool thing i don't know
i ain't buying it dude
in the media's portrayal of this story
i know what i saw an actual father here
like a bart
where's bart he doesn't know anything
dude oh [ __ ] his kid could barely speak
yeah dude
oh my god so again he he has been dubbed
father of the year after he
saved so early
still only march you know from a series
cody hooks was competing in the prca
rodeo at the bell county expo center in
central texas when he fell off his bowl
18 year old was only seconds into his
ride when he hit the deck and he was
knocked unconscious like you saw in the
that's the way but the bull continued to
kick ferociously in the ring while bull
fighters tried to contain it all while
cody's motionless body lay on the floor
i think motionless is an incorrect word
he was kind of like spazzing out a
little bit yeah whoa he was pretty stiff
did he hit the ground with his head yeah
probably yeah that's probably he it
looks like he he like fell an impact
yeah he like dunked it down
without skipping a beat the teen's dad
landis bravely jumped in the ring and
threw himself on his son to protect
him protect i'm just making sure no
that's the narrative weird thought yeah
that's that's what they're pushing out
there damn that's that's crazy because
like i don't even know if my instinct
would be to do that i might just stand
in front of them like come on big guy
just drag his feet out yeah like just
pull it drag him yeah just drag her
distract a guy who's having a seizure
pick them up like this and then
what you're supposed to do if your guys
having a seizure you pick them up yeah
and you walk them somewhere
that's what you do yeah you pick them up
and then you you hit it back you let
them cough the seizures gotta get them
to burp the seizure up you cough
you know your sister bud as you tell
them
that is medical advice by the way you
should definitely remember that don't
remember that dude that's some brave
[ __ ] though dude that's super brilliant
have you seen all those like
compilations of dad [ __ ] saving the
day moments where like a ball will come
and he's like bam he'll grab that kid
falls yeah and he catches the kid by the
leg have you seen the ones with the moms
it's called mom's doing what's expected
compilation thing exactly
it was really short those three seconds
long
it was only one
there's a half a clip
have you seen those whether like when
moms do it it's just normal but when men
do it it's like this big exhilarating
thing
really yeah there's like that's like a
social thing i didn't know that really
yeah they think like men get commended
for doing [ __ ] that moms do normally
huh i guess that's kind of true when you
see a guy with his kid like a little
baby it's like oh wow what a great dad
but if you see a mom it's like
that is a mom i mean it's because the
bar is set so low for men
[ __ ] you know it's like holy [ __ ] he's
fathering yeah yeah you gotta you gotta
reinforce positive behavior so it keeps
happening that's why that's why it's
it's remarkable because i tell you this
my dad didn't [ __ ] jump when on me
when the bulls came that's who ran out
of the stadium so
in life really huh
that was said oh [ __ ] there's a [ __ ]
blue oh no he said wait joe's here
i didn't know i was trying to go to a
rodeo
and then years later he's like i don't
remember that
he's a what bull what [ __ ]
i don't remember a bull i remember some
[ __ ]
that's funny though yeah i've seen those
compilations i haven't seen a
compilation of moms [ __ ] slapping
baseballs out of the face you know the
ones are pretty crazy though they're
pretty unique you know what i mean like
kids falling back is there mom ones
though i never seen the mom i was lying
it was not
not even one video there's gotta be one
we just type it in i'm not gonna youtube
you know
don't you get zero results you know what
the dad ones remind me of though there's
something very primal looking about it
like it looks like caveman just chilling
there [ __ ] because they're like a
gazelle or something like whatever and
then something calms like a big rock and
it just boom
hits it out of the way ooga yeah ooga
booga booga grabbing the kid by the
[ __ ] lag
and what would the mom do
she's out mothering
nowhere to be found in these videos
yeah that's what i think have you seen
the one there's like an indoor camera
you don't have those indoor cameras that
are like you people watch their houses
with and [ __ ] and it's a dad and he's
telling his kid he'll be right back and
he just leaves and then he never comes
back
there's a lot of those too out there a
lot of those out there
what do the comments say about the dads
in there um you know
not in very nice things
like that is not a good thought so
that's why we need the positive
reinforcement yes yeah [ __ ] like that's
going to happen
you got to get the most basic [ __ ] and
go damn
that was awesome felt so [ __ ] awesome
oh wow
you caught him
good job honey
because most dads would just be like
playing the games like man get the [ __ ]
racked up yeah
dude catch him because he's holding the
controller and he's like ah damn
that's one of the saddest things is if
if you play call of duty with like
public server you hear a lot of people
like yelling at their little babies yeah
to shut up while they play really you
hear that [ __ ] every [ __ ] it's almost
exclusive and then everyone else in the
lobby is also telling that yeah they're
they're that yeah shut your [ __ ] kid
up get here
it's the best thing yeah dude they're
just like
you're probably my least favorite race
too
yeah there's so much of that on there
it's crazy a lot of racial slurs on the
end oh yeah game chats that's why it's
like if you grow up [ __ ] xbox
generation that should have been fake
you're just like dude you want to stop
that [ __ ] start there yeah cause these
are [ __ ] kids man
that's true i wonder if they'll get
demonetized
supposedly something can detect now
i like this head thing today
joe always coming from a past trauma
i would have the okay oh yeah what if
they get some strikes i think
[Laughter]
yeah they should censor that server i
think if there's even like because it
can detect now i think like if you're
saying some racial [ __ ] really yeah they
have that technology what if they're
just being mandarin huh
but they can't detect when it's a gender
thing though what if you're just telling
the truth though
[ __ ] i don't know that
they'll go to the [ __ ] high court
oh okay
the high court of of call of duty
actually super racist guy he's like i'm
just telling truth i don't [ __ ]
understand how do i escalate this
who do i call yeah i'll talk to your
manager that's fine
yeah i said those things yeah who's your
manager the interior of labor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you